cars today are far more complex than
ever before they need anywhere from
several hundred semiconductors to more
than a thousand and these chips control
everything from the ignition to the
braking system and making sure your seat
is in the perfect position as you drive
individual chips they're packaged inside
these electronic control units they sort
of act as almost like separate organs
that have a different function in the
human body they basically tell the
hardware what to do electronically
but now automakers can't Source the
semiconductors fast enough and many cars
are sitting in parking lots waiting for
chips because during the pandemic ships
for vehicles were diverted to meet a
surge in demand for electronics as
people were stuck at home and their
availability has become tighter also
because of natural disasters that
disrupted the supply chain and the
Resurgence of coveted cases in important
chip making regions this crunch could
cause global automakers around 110
billion dollars in Revenue this year
this crisis has really forced automakers
to kind of rethink both in the
short-term and the long term how they
how they manage their their chips and
their supply chain so here's how
companies are adjusting their production
plans and what that means the next time
you want to drive a car off the lot
one of the first Solutions when you
don't have enough of something try to
use less
so some water makers are dropping
features that require chips they're sort
of small add-on features uh I think
people have been willing to overlook
that some car dealers in the U.S said
the global auto company stalantis which
owns Jeep Ram and other brands ships and
pickup trucks without an electronic
detection system which looks out for
blind spots in another example GM said
it was building some full-size pickup
trucks without software that helps
manage fuel consumption and Elon Musk
said that Tesla was removing the
adjustable lumbar support from the front
passenger seat of some Vehicles due to
Major industry-wide supply chain
pressure it hasn't been a big hit sort
of reputationally or from a market share
standpoint that they've been kind of
forced to take that step for instance
stalantis reported more than 89 billion
dollars in net revenue in the first half
of this year while General Motors had a
strong second quarter with 2.8 billion
dollars in net profit
but automakers have had to make some
tough choices like choosing between
Vehicles car companies are all trying to
figure out what prioritize what they
want to make and what can be sacrificed
for instance General Motors said it's
been shifting computer chips away from
its less profitable vehicles and using
them in its more popular ones
but even with diverting inventory
there's no guarantee that there will be
enough chips for the vehicles that have
been prioritized when they may not have
one of the chips that they need they'll
continue to build those vehicles and
then they're setting them aside in
parking lots around the factory and
waiting for chips to arrive this is what
some in the industry called the build
shy strategy the good part about that
strategy is it it allows them to keep
the factory running because it's costly
to keep turning off and turning back on
your factory but this can mean chipless
cars end up sitting on the lot for an
indefinite amount of time Ford said that
at the end of March it had more than
twenty thousand Vehicles parked and
waiting for chips GM over the summer
they said they had 30 000 pickup trucks
at a plant in Missouri
while these strategies have helped
companies to keep going in the short
term it's also forced them to plan for
the future by rethinking the entire
process for decades the Auto industry is
is really kind of perfected this just in
time model where components arrive at
the factory and even right at the
assembly line
just as they're needed that allows them
to lower their inventory costs and
there's a lot of efficiencies that go
with that but the chip shortage has
shown this model breaks down during a
global crisis like the pandemic
companies are looking at moving to
stockpiling really crucial computer
chips there's been direct Outreach from
you know Auto Executives to chip
suppliers which you know hadn't been
happening in the past and audio
companies not only want more visibility
in the supply chain but also more Direct
Control some of the companies have
talked about even getting more involved
in designing their own chips designing
components to need fewer chips I know
Ford specifically has talked about that
this is infrastructure there's also a
big push from the US government to shore
up its own domestic chip making capacity
the Biden Administration has said it
would prioritize increasing domestic
chip manufacturing by investing roughly
50 billion dollars toward research and
development
but building new foundries and
increasing chip production will take
years and that means automakers will
likely continue to scale back production
in early September GM said it's
temporarily idling two main factories
that produce its pickup trucks while
Ford said it's temporarily halting the
production of its F-150 at its Kansas
City Factory in Missouri even some of
the more chip ready automakers like
Toyota said it would cut production in
Japan by 40 in September and in the
short run all this won't be good news
for customers there just simply Aren't
Enough cars usually Americans want to
drive off in a car that day and that's
not happening nearly to the same degree
as it normally has